I think that most people are scared to
do stuff because they're not sure if
it's going to work but it's definitely
not going to work if you're going to
just keep talking to each other that's
guaranteed it's guaranteed that
nothing's going to happen if you keep
talking to each other
and there's a high percentage shift that
it won't work out but at least you won't
regret it in 13 years that you never did
it well listen it's a real pleasure to
be with you I'm thrilled to answer
anything uh any way I can provide value
so let's just maximize time before they
drag me on stage so anybody fire away
sorry for the last couple of days it's
become really clear that you're all
about being
yeah and providing value yes
and you said yesterday that you never
get asked this question so here it is as
content creators how can we provide our
audience yeah what he's referencing is I
I believe that a lot of people hit you
know all of you on your journey and we
you know I've been really focusing on
this space since 2006. it's a long time
back to being 10 years you know I'm like
[__] I'm sold 10 years right you know
but it's very clear to me you know 15
almost 20 years later
everyone here has gotten to a place
based on their talent their creativity
their work ethic and like anyone in
anything then especially in this game
with an audience you then hit a place
you're in a place like of course you
keep growing but like there's a place
and I think the thing that I'm most
fascinated by is If people could really
take that next step with themselves and
say okay I've been producing
in a manner that has a lot of energy
towards what am I going to get out of it
I want to be famous I want to make money
I want to send them to our page and turn
them into a paying customer I want more
followers I want more likes I want like
if you can make that shift to
why would anybody want to watch this
thing that I'm about to post it can make
them laugh that's escapism you may be an
attractive person that brings value you
may give business advice there's a
million reasons why something could be
valuable
but really starting to push yourself
into like what's very clear what works
for me and what I see in others that
take the next steps is genuinely like
pushing yourself to try to provide
actual value
actually and so that's it it's not a
super complex it's kind of like I think
of these things similar to the way I
think about health and fitness like it's
not that complicated to get into better
shape
like there is a calorie situation
there's a protein situation there's
going to the actual gym and doing it of
course there's technique if you want to
maximize your muscles but the reality is
it's not so complicated
it's hard to do
right you know it's what I just said is
profoundly simple do you think every
time you post how is this actually
bringing value or do you think about
this is going to do well and get me more
followers or this is going to lead to
sales of a t-shirt or this and that and
so but I don't I think people should
worry about what they want I'm talking
about a group like this that's already
gotten to a real place and is thinking
about how do I get to the next place and
I think adding the element of
selflessness
is a incredible formula for growth and
it feels nice
thank you you're welcome I've got an
interesting one actually so please no
worries brother no worries
um but like kind of jumping off that day
what's your thoughts on you know how
it's like the 80 20 rule here for making
money so like in business venture
towards what that 80 is the most and
then whatever else is left over is the
20 what if that 20 is the the [__] that
you really love to do but it's not
making that much money 80 is what's
making you all your
would you split that lower to 50 50 or
would you keep doing the 80 20 till the
20 becomes 40 or something my goal would
be for the second thing to be a hundred
and then live within the means of what
that provides
I think that's the ultimate goal of a
human being like I really question the
concept of
the next variable after one makes the
money so if you think about it right
you're saying hey
80 is where it makes the money 20 is
what brings me to happiness
my you know if we're having dinner for
four hours and become great great
friends over time I'm looking forward to
it you know from scene to best friends
right you know like
to me the
question I have with all the people that
most are important to me is let's just
play this out like what's the money for
how much money for what and like what
ends up happening is what I know is that
when you're how old are you Dad
I'm 47 right so we're in a different
place than a lot of people in this room
I know that the people that I talk to
that are a generation above us 82 91
like the Money Talk starts to dissipate
very quickly and so the question becomes
you know my recommendation is to spend
as much time as possible on the 20
percent
you know because happiness is just so
much more sustainable and more
importantly what are you doing with the
money that you make on the 80 percent I
think most people are buying what a
proxy to happiness not actual happiness
they think they're buying happiness but
it's not their actual happiness
and so I'm very fascinated by that
question
I would push you as much as possible to
the other stuff as much as humanly
possible
vlogging good for you brother and what
you know if if vlogging is your 20 then
you're starting to go into my territory
my happiness comes from being a
businessman when I was five or six or
seven or third when everyone in high
school was trying to like party and hook
up and have fun the most fun thing for
me was going to the flea market and
selling [__] that was more fun for me
you know what I mean like I really like
it more like I like it more than going
to a concert though I understand that
that's a minority I can't help my
chemicals it is more fun for me to go to
the baseball card show or to work at my
dad's liquor store stocking shelves than
to do what most people find fun
that worked out for me because what I
find the most enjoyable and fun I was
and that I was naturally good at also
has a direct correlation to creating
money
if your fun is vlogging
that as a direct correlation to making
money because you're building brand and
awareness yeah to my 80 percent is like
different content
like transition content I've still got
like employees and stuff like that I
totally understand the question the the
other side of the pillow of what we were
just talking about is the tolerance for
the 80 percent
the other thing that's interesting is
when you're doing something that is
paying for your livelihood where are you
are you in I used to [__] love it and
now I just like it that's [__]
amazing
uh I've always I kind of used to like it
and now I'm just kind of like whatever
with it like neutral still pretty good
I've never really loved it and now I
[__] hate it now I'm starting to get
scared that's where I've seen so many of
my friends and so many people for so
many years starting to get into a
dangerous place because hate it starts
to leave uh opening for them to take
their money and spend it on [__] to
close the gap on them hating their
day-to-day which gets into dangerous
territory so you know for all the people
that are tolerating or going through the
reality of there's something that
provides you the money and you're not
doing your passion I just need to know
where you sit on that like
kind of okay I can tolerate it when it
starts bleeding into I hate it you have
to be careful
very good thank you you're welcome
brother
because what I see so often is when they
hate it then what they're using their
money for is to close the gap on pain
and that gets into alcoholism and drugs
and thrills and womanizing and just went
out like all the stuff that can really
ultimately lead to
hitting rock bottom emotionally
well that I like UFC cards are good
um wait what do you think so we struggle
a lot with getting videos demonetized
and censorships and stuff like that what
do you think social media is going I
think they'll be I think they'll be
decentralized social networks built on
the blockchain that'll have no no
censorship and you'll be like you know
how athletes that are professional
athletes are always mad at the Next
Generation because they make much more
money but they're not as good at them uh
you'll have that same feeling they'll be
in 15 years there'll be a crew and
you're gonna look at them and be like
they're not even as good as us but they
don't have the same headaches you had
because that's just how the world works
but you have it better than the people
20 years ago that had to go to Hollywood
and be discovered
do you think platforms like Rumble and
Twitter because they know obviously
censor anything do you think they'll
start growing and overtaking the others
or do you open no I think it's been very
proven that things that are censored are
always a smaller Niche than things that
aren't
I don't feel overtake I think you'll
have options
you know what I mean yeah yeah you know
it's not they won't overtake and what
gets censored changes over time too yeah
you know what we deem as censorable or
like my career
um which we've talked about a couple
times on this trip because Steve and it
works at Vayner speakers and we've known
each other a long time before he worked
with me and like I mean I was told to my
face that I could never be a big speaker
in 2009 because I cursed too much
and that I dress too casual for the
business crowd
so you know I think and I left a lot of
money on the table just like you're
leaving money on the table because you
can't monetize against things of that
nature it goes back to his question
are you going to change are you just
going to be patient to when you know
when that becomes the game yeah
you could also do what you're doing
content-wise you could make content that
is beeping out or slightly more edited
and social but then drive them to your
environment and be what as crazy as
[__] you want to be literally and as
you should so don't be philosophical or
emotional about it
double down on the truth one of the
biggest strengths I have is I leave my
feelings at the door when I do business
instead of being like [__] the system
and you know might just make [__]
mundane content like with beeps and
slightly altered and censored and drive
it to my site and you know because every
every minute that you two say [__] you
know meta or Instagram or Tick Tock is a
second that you're not putting into
creativity to drive people to go to your
website
fighting
the punch line is not interesting
give it no energy
and then where people get caught is they
go to rumble and they think like or this
and they're like but it's a small
percent like they're they're cutting
their nose to spite their face
proving nothing to nobody
they're just getting steamed in their
own room like this is where the whole
world is right now they're just [__]
festering with each other on some [__]
that doesn't mean anything yeah yeah
make [__] one make the sense of
content social and safe and mop and live
your happiness
yes brother a lot of things like I'm a
bit different to the other people in
this room okay or anything like that at
the moment uh at the moment I'm doing
like sales and everything yes that's a
really good skill to learn it is um
and a few of my friends are YouTubers
and everything and they tell me hi
Jameson you'd be great on the camera you
can talk to people you're
moving your hands and everything I'm
like yeah do you want to yeah I do okay
Harry and I were thinking like because
he wants to change up his content a
little bit he obviously needs someone in
front of a camera
um so like it's just transitioning into
that because obviously there's a lot of
that why can't why do you have to
transition why don't you just do both
for a Time
yeah well it's also actually doing the
kind because we talk about it all the
time like doing videos and stuff like
that but it never actually gets what are
you guys scared of
no I don't know
probably I'm just safe with what I can
do which is the festival yep honors yeah
yeah I get makes sense so it's like well
it's what you can do now
I think that most people are scared to
do stuff because they're not sure if
it's gonna work
but it's definitely not going to work if
you're going to just keep talking to
each other
that's guaranteed yeah
I mean it's guaranteed that nothing's
gonna happen if you keep talking to each
other
and there's a high percentage chance
that it won't work out but at least you
won't regret it in 13 years and that you
never did it
regret is the poison of society
you know like you just gotta get you
know I think the thing to think about is
like what are you going to get made fun
of by your friends because your YouTube
channel didn't do well who gives a [__]
you know what I mean like they're not in
junior high yeah like it's gonna be okay
yeah of course
right and I learned so much from that
where I could grow more from that so
those things are starting up you've
learned from that and you can grow and
become bigger from now and there's
people and there's people who fail 16
times in a row and decide to never try
again but at least when they go into the
ground they need they knew they took a
[__] swing
have you had any failures of recent
years businesses or like
yes in the micro of them not in the
macro
you know but I'm also an extremely
experienced operator who like has a
really good sense of like what he does
you know like most of the business like
I'm I'm extremely good at my craft but I
would fail at most things
that I wasn't good at my craft and I was
doing for the first time
like you know I got my ass kicked the
first time I played pickleball
I'm taking up Jiu Jitsu in September I
don't think it's going to go very well
the first year I have a funny feeling
I'm gonna get hurt and lose a lot
like you know so you know for me in
business you're now talking about the
place I've been training since I was six
like and I had natural talent in it
and I don't even logically know how to
launch a business that would fail yeah
like I don't even know how to do that no
different than people here
would couldn't fail at the thing that
they were meant to do like if you're
funny or like if you have athletic
ability like there's some people are
just athletic and the first time they do
anything it's going to be pretty [__]
solid they'll hone their skills but
they're athletic it I'm not capable of
starting a business that's going to fail
if I'm running it I've had a lot of
failures where I'm like kind of like
partners with someone and I'm not doing
it or I'm like helping out but if I'm
driving the [__] car there's no
[__] chance but that's also because
I'm 40 years into practice and I was
naturally good at it if you've never
done it
if you go from never doing it to having
a business well that makes a [__] ton
of sense like if I was forced right now
to sing a [__] concert it would be a
[__] [__] show
you know but do but do I but do I think
in 13 years I could put on something
that was at least serviceable with 13
years of [__] singing lessons I do at
least serviceable probably not good
because it wasn't an app I'm not [__]
Beyonce
but it'll be a hell of a lot better than
if I just went out there and sang
[__] nine songs right now
there'll be like three people left in
the [__] crowd you know so I think I
think we don't talk enough about that
with business yeah everyone's like I'm
just gonna be a Creator and I'm just
gonna run a business I'm like okay
[__] Mazel Tov but like if you've
never [__] tried like this is gonna
be gnarly
you know like I I made videos
on YouTube in February of 2006 every day
till today I've made video content on
the internet every day since pretty much
I mean there's you know and so like
that's a lot of practice
but the first time I spoke in 2007 it
was good because I was naturally
talented at it and then I got better and
so like people spend too much time
wanting to be something they're not
instead of analyzing who they are and
then you make decisions back to that
question you just might want to be a
rapper then it's okay to be a
non-commercially successful rapper
because it gives you tremendous joy and
if you live within the means of what
you've been able to accomplish with
being the 70th trillionth best rapper in
the world that's a happy life
these are the convos we need to have
more of
um I prepared something for you yep you
spend a lot of time on this one I would
love to share with you if that's cool
I'm happy to do it I love magic could we
go on that table because I didn't see
the table sure
we're here with Gary I am here Gary have
you ever heard of a card story before no
you've never heard of it nope I wrote a
story with a pack of cards okay I'm
gonna Shuffle these cots just like so
give it a saksham shuffle
all the cards you can see they're all
normal air all the cards
yeah well hold on is this normal is that
a joker that's a joker yeah
this story is about a guy
named Jack okay he was born in
1975. that's me oh
but what's crazy is he had a mom he has
that and Jack at the age of just eight
years old it's not a lemonade stall and
he started setting lemonade but 25 cents
what crazy right when he was only one
four fourteen he started making two
thousand dollars per week doing all his
business card sales all that card
selling that's amazing Vayner media
Vader X started making tense hundreds
thousands millions of dollars
crazy respect right there right
here we have two zero two one the year
20 21. he had over 8.9 million followers
on Instagram three point six million
Twitter follows and 3.4 million YouTube
subscribers with over 300
379 million Channel views pretty crazy
fan but yeah
he was impressing all the ladies
today the man is 47 years old written
six books and I'm not joking Gary
these six books he wrote
Jack had over five times New York
bestseller that's round of course right
there guys come on that's a big thing
he's telling people Ace life literally
with his content he's helping people to
Ace life
Jack had one dream
to buy the New York Jets which is
currently worth 5.4 billion dollars
but wait
why does he want to do this
is his mom
the real reason
was because of his mom because when this
guy was only seven years old
he wanted to buy the jersey and couldn't
afford it at the time so he made a dream
he would buy that that Jersey
go to that Stadium
own the team
put it right in front of it
and you know how long it took his mom
to make that Jersey
three weeks
that is incredible thank you brother
that was really well done thank you
thank you for doing that give me a hug
that was really nice really nice brother
you really inspired me so much in the
past 10 years of my life and I've been
doing magic acting I got I've been I've
got a lot of opportunities through
YouTube because I've been grinding on
social I watched the video of yours when
you like everything's 20 video for 20
year olds yes and it was like high risk
yep and I was the beginning of the I
finished my University degree in
marketing media I was doing a lot of
crazy stuff here with filming you know
magic and all that I went to LA
and I started studying acting yeah over
there
um I ended up getting a manager in
acting and I started working a lot over
there as well and then I recently did my
first feature film yes produced by Dev
Patel called not so it's been a hell of
a journey and I just wanted to say that
this was amazing you have really you
know thank you very much
[Applause]
amazing so well done it's crazy it's
good [__] it's amazing it's so well done
emotional yeah it's really good thank
you buddy a few more minutes okay
do you want to go down the shoot yeah
that'd be great all right let's keep
going I want to maximum thank you
brother yes go ahead with yours um so
obviously you make a lot of content do
you have to see the editing process do
you get your editors to like a fine-tune
what they're doing like dude they're
they're working we have a WhatsApp the
whole team's on it I will give feedback
but I'm pretty big on like
letting them have the creative freedom
posting and learning post game
so I'll say things there's a lot of
feedback I won't post it if I don't like
it but what would you say I would say
almost 50 percent of what you do anymore
I would say like 50 to 70 of what the
team makes I don't post
yeah because I didn't feel it doesn't
feel right A lot of times I write all
the copy so a lot of times the video
will get to a place and I know I can get
my point across by adding the copy
um but then we have a lot we have
meetings I add my two cents I talk about
things like it's a constant conversation
but I'm not I'm very built in the volume
and putting it out I also like learning
I also like when I didn't like it and it
does well I'm learning
going back to Maitland's question before
the 1820 yes
um how do you get better with time
management when you've got so much going
on and all are doing really well I'm
very good at that so I can this is
something I'm confident in I guess
because
um and they're all different types of
businesses too so you've got your ad
reference I got it then uh another one's
a vlog Channel which um generates
Revenue to the merchandise or food sales
yep and then you have a subscription
yeah you've just got so many things so
important to your business
um but you just constantly flat out how
do you get better with trying to manage
your time a bit better people
what about when it's a brand so revolved
around you people
he just asked me about my own content
that is me and I said giving people
freedom
it's me
um people
you have a hat you have a direct leader
for every one of the different
businesses
and you have people that manage like you
have real admins to manage your time
your time is your game I have I would
say that 30 of my meetings Monday
through Friday or 15 minutes or less
yeah
yeah what if you're not in the position
someone
stop buying stuff
you know what I mean brother like like
like
invest in your business and your
infrastructure before you buy the stuff
like when it's you know like like if we
were like boys I'd be like show me
everything I'd be like do not buy a
[__] Prada bag
keep that and [__] employ someone
like that to me is [__] religion you
know
like you can afford it because by the
way everyone in here has achieved
something that almost every 18 year old
wants everyone's different but we're so
like rigid but that would be my answer
you can afford it there's different ways
to think about it you know what I mean
you know first I look at your life first
I go into accountability of like your
lifestyle like live a little less bougie
and get an admin and then I go into like
and some people like [__] you Gary I
don't have anything I don't buy anything
I'm like okay let's go next thing you do
have your platform and people want your
platform they want access to your
platform they think you're cool
of course brother whole world of AI is
obviously massive in the future yes how
do you think that can be brought into
like content creation and how are you
it's going to be I mean it's already
massive like have you played with it
have you played with that uh yes but I
don't really know how to apply it to
anything my I have 30 employees whose
job it is to watch all the footage right
now and find the best moments and we've
already tested
rudimentary AI That's better than them
anybody need Dustin you know you know
what I mean like like right like like
like but but it's not like it it'll just
make them do different things
yeah like it's gonna save them time it's
not like oh now you're fine like they'll
do different things they'll be it's this
when the tractor was invented in 1860 80
of the world worked on a farm
then we met the tractors and we didn't
have to do that anymore we did different
[__] so I don't think this everyone's
demonizing ai ai is going to commoditize
certain things and if you are a Adobe
Photoshop designer that doesn't have a
thought to their brain and you make
everything that someone else tells you
you might be in trouble
but if you are a Adobe Photoshop
designer that thinks their ass off as
they make their stuff that's not being
replaced tomorrow but it's going to
massively impact uh
um massively impact content creation
it's going to massively impact
everything
I gotta go thank you everyone
[Music]